eu só está enganando você e aí ela quer
deixar o campeonato você hoje eu estou
aqui na casa o radiante page
hoje vocês sabem que eu estou agora eu
estou na minha e aí facial galera olha
só o antigo e hoje chegou à marca de 100
vídeos no canal porque é sem vício é
muito fácil de ser vice e quiser eu fico
faça um vídeo de um minuto o importante
é dar 100 vídeo que só dá sim mas eu ou
algum tempo eu firmei o compromisso é de
todo o sábado e toda quarta volta no
vídeo e na o impasse que lá acho que se
a cantar lugar de cama de alguém fala o
vídeo enviado a esquecer de carregar a
cama pega a câmera de outra pessoa e irá
à jogando capoeira não deu fazer ouvir
pega o bolton five banda capoeira
ai eu tive um acidente o samu vai buscar
eu pedi que os ônibus caminhão também no
mercado não sabe ou não quer ficar na
cama na casa do celular grave e eu fico
feliz eu fico muito feliz por você
assistir meus vídeos porque tem muita
coisa que assistir à televisão net zorra
total e a praça é nossa também em a
fazenda
a ordem tem que só programa topa e em
vez de você está assistindo isso você
está aqui é você mesmo que está
assistindo esse vídeo é agora você
poderia estar fazendo algo muito mais
importante é não está onde está aqui o
meu vídeo você está assistindo meu filho
então isso pra mim é muito gratificante
e eu fico feliz por vocês gostaram meus
vídeos mesmo 26 entre coisa simples por
exemplo agora eu tô num evento social
vai dividir o canal do índice não tem
abertura do canal doentes não têm
panenka natrumse luterana em canal que
não tem um [ __ ] nenhum e tem uma galera
muito boa que gosta de assistir eu faço
vídeo de otto do eu faço coisas idiotas
e todo mundo gosta de pj todo mundo é
idiota e eu sou idiota também porque eu
faço parte da massa de ontem e aí vocês
assistir as coisas de outra porque eu
sei que vocês querem chegar da escola
você não quer ver você não quer ver
gente morrendo você não quer ver guerra
você não quer mesmo você quer ver coisa
que deixa você feliz e eu e meu filho eu
fico muito feliz não sabe que eu sou uma
das coisas que deixam vocês felizes
então muito obrigado por você
você assiste os meus vídeos e eu espero
que você assista mais resto da vida e
até quando falar assim galera poder
okamotto
agora não vai ter que falar fazer alguma
outra coisa a gente vai ter que vender
cremosinho e é está é isso que eu estou
o cão eu tô campo que eu não dormi
direito eu não sei mais o sentido da
minha vida nem sempre como fazemos aqui
cara não devia estar aqui o dever de
evitar procurá-lo a vida podia tá você
na praia e agora mas notou que gravar um
vídeo pra você na verdade eu não podia
estar na praia não mas eu falei isso
porque nessa hora pois pode encontrar
não quer quiser mas realmente não posso
sem vídeos em vídeos que são 100 vídeo é
tipo um vídeo só que sempre eles é muita
coisa você leva uma paulada na cabeça
deve doer muito antes você levar 100
paulada na cabeça o [ __ ] é bom você
mostrar o pau lado 38
então isso para provar aqui e está
propensa a provar que nada há nada que
eu tô falando bem porque eu acho que é
um é uma marca boa não 100 vídeos que eu
parei pra falar senão tanquinhos
entreter uma galera e tem uma galera que
precisa poderia parar de fazer filha
poderia fazer 21 em uma semana de 12 da
semana mas eu vou manter a freqüência de
fazer política porque eu quero ver vocês
sorriram gosto de ver os comentários de
vocês acham márcio francisco mental no
cu
apareça mera crujo isso agentes internet
incluídas que só tem sido um mero entrar
nesse 4º cbo
eu acho massa do dosh muito massa e eu
quero fazer 200 e depois 500 depois 1000
e 1500 e depois 2000 depois de 1500
depois 3.000 3525 cara vai fazer eu
queria agradecer também é que eu queria
agradecer eu queria agradecer eu tenho
muitos fãs clubes
o phantom windows do pernambuco fã clube
da bahia fã clube do cantor do ceará da
manaus o clube de santa cruz dos
milagres o convidar a virgem de
guadalupe do méxico estão muito fã clube
eu quero que eu queria agradecer a todos
vocês que pedem tem gente sai um vídeo
curto isso cara você não sabe quantos me
ajudando sempre ajuda de mais cedo
demais oito se eu pudesse eu dava um
beijo na boca de vocês vai embora eu
dava um beijo você nunca mais esquecer
do meu beijo ou seja eu querer casar
comigo e comprar uma casa da caixa
econômica e tem 11 filha de um no
feminino e um cachorro e ea gente é ser
feliz para sempre
caso você não tenha galera sério você me
ajuda muito quando por exemplo você
quando você aquela galera é fácil e nem
assistiu o vídeo já que quem gostei
[ __ ] da edição a confiança do [ __ ] e
mais por vocês já da light porque você
já sabe que eu não vou falar besteira
só confiança muito boa eu acho eu acho
muito bom isso que eu queria pedir eu
queria pedir a vocês é obrigado a olhar
sério obrigado nem você sente por pegar
todo mundo me segue no twitter galera
que sai no dia que toda toda a madrugada
e aí galera medição aponta todo mundo
presente lá pô matou hoje tudo é muito
bom isso então muito obrigado por você
tá comigo se 100 vídeo cd você fique
comigo pelos 500 pelos 1 mil pelos 1500
2000 para 1500 mil 3535 4408 e também
muitos vindos de toda a minha vida e
agora opositor mitológica eu tenho nessa
maneira ainda o irmão na minha fé na
praia mas então eu acho que eu vou
dormir e sei que eu queria eu acho que
esse ano será num mês e agora eu entendi
tarde faleceu eu não posso morrer agora
porque eu disse não conhecer do satélite
é preciso conhecer da técnica não posso
morrer na mesa do consumidor
então você e você que tá aí comigo desde
sempre você vai estar me desse a gente
já gostei desse vídeo quilos das redes
sociais cair na descrição do vídeo aqui
em baixo pode porque vai me acompanhar é
que não quiser também eu também nunca
quem saiu para jogar por ser na vida que
elas têm a ver com os seus tempos como
perceber o outro então que nasce criança
e cada comunidade pensa nesse dia
fazendo outra coisa vai poder então é
fazer caridade é fazer alguma coisa aí
pronto aí gama ele não vai fazer uma
coisa cara é obrigado a fazer nada mas
se você quiser me seguir à revolução nos
cinemas no dia como passando posso fazer
nada não sou ninguém senhor jesus só
deus para ajudar só deu não só demos um
dos aviões o que é solicitado e último
módulo internacional street tempo
[Música]